sie sind zu gast bei maybrit illner und
sie begrüßt die gäste der sendung noch
mal sehr herzlich einen schönen guten
abend liebe zuschauer aus dem stillstand
geht es für manche direkt in den
aufstand
über 5000 in stuttgart 3000 in münchen
1000 in berlin nach der schockstarre die
proteste die zweifel wachsen
war und ist der lotter und
verhältnismäßig wieviel bevormundung
verträgt die demokratie zum zweiten mal
als familie und der hauptgrund ist
einfach der dass sie maßnahmen unsere
meinung nach einfach weit überzogen sind
83 millionen gesunde menschen in
quarantäne zu schicken und aufhängen zu
sperren und die wirtschaft rund
es ist ja was ist jetzt noch überhaupt
überhaupt für die ganze familie
behandelt wird finde ich ein bisschen
überzogen
viele hier bezweifeln die aussagekraft
der daten
geschätzte infizierten zahlen
geschätzter reproduktions faktor
geschätzte sterblichkeitsrate mit ihrer
kritik stehen sie mittlerweile nicht
allein der wissenschaftlichen wert haben
die zahlen eigentlich dann gar nicht bei
epidemie ist es war wichtig zu fragen
wie viele leute sind wirklich infiziert
das eilig errichtete not krankenhaus auf
dem berliner messegelände symbol eines
fehlalarms in dem maße wie das was sie
machen auch wirksam wird
in dem maße schwindet einfach auch etwas
die einsicht dass man sich hier noch
weiter an diese scharfen maßnahmen
halten soll soll weiß sie haben ja schon
gewirkt
es ist ein dilemma für die politik
denn überall versuchen
verschwörungstheoretiker rechts und
linksextreme die proteste anzuheizen und
für sich zu kapern der korona frust als
plattform für extremisten bei uns ist
christiane woopen chefin des
europäischen ethikrates verwoben überall
purzeln die einschränkungen unseres
lebens und gleichzeitig wächst der
protest kann man das erklären
wie passt das zusammen also ich finde
dass man das sehr gut nachvollziehen
kann denn das ich werde ich erst mal mit
einem medizinischen phänomen das nennt
sich zentralisierung wenn der körper im
schockzustand ist dann konzentriert sich
alles darauf dass die lebenswichtigen
organe versorgt werden und die
peripherie bleibt ein bisschen ruhiger
und wenn dann der schock zustand weg ist
und er bezieht sicher hat sich auch in
deutschland auf alle bezogen dann
differenzierte sich aus und der körper
der hat dafür natürliche regeln das
funktioniert die gesellschaft und die
politik müssen sich entscheiden für
etwas die müssen regeln definieren und
das war ein ausgesprochen schwieriger
prozess
er wurde auch wohl ein bisschen zu spät
begonnen dass man ihn wirklich als
strategie und als konzept begründet hat
und dementsprechend sind auch einige ein
bisschen verzweifelt darüber und sagen
dann so etwas wie würde meine oma doch
im zoo leben dann könnte ich sie
besuchen die fußballer brennen
umeinander herum aber ich darf meine
mutter im altenheim nicht in den arm
nehmen
das sind dinge wo ganz schnell
glaubwürdigkeitsverluste entstehen
denn bei diesen sogenannten hygiene
demos jetzt auch radikale und irgendwie
auch gewaltbereite demonstranten dabei
sind ist es dann trotzdem klug
grundsätzlich dazu zu sagen das sind
alles verrückte nein ich glaube dass es
gerade falsch sie als verrückt
bezeichnen da hat jeder
wir haben da jetzt mit einer gemenge
lage zu tun da mischen sich jetzt die
faschistische orientierten mit den
impfgegnern mit anderen radikalen
gruppen und so weiter und ich glaube wir
sollten sehr aufmerksam sein was da
gerade für ein
es brauch mit angst und sorge und
existenzieller not stattfindet denn es
ist natürlich jetzt sehr viel angst und
unsicherheit entstanden viele menschen
ist der boden unter den füßen weggezogen
worden und die wissen nicht wie ihr
leben so weitergehen soll wie sie es
eigentlich führen wollen würden
und insofern glaube ich müssen wir da
jetzt mal hinhören das ernstnehmen not
abwenden und da sein und nicht überall
schon wieder etiketten draufkleben
wer sagt das klären wir gleich da hat
sich schon nikolaus hofer gebildet vom
spiegel frage erst mal an tobias hans
herren sind war ja so interessant dass
zuerst im saarland und nicht nur im
saarland richter geurteilt haben
dass manche dieser maßnahmen diese
lockdown maßnahmen zu weit gingen
sind sie eigentlich froh darüber dass
die bürger trotz dieser krise und in
dieser krise so skeptisch und kritisch
bleiben
natürlich ist es wichtig also wir haben
auch im saarland obwohl wir sehr strenge
maßnahmen hatten wir hatten ja ausgangs
beschränkungen sowie auch in bayern nach
dem österreichischen vorbild und wir
haben trotzdem als erstes bundesland
gesagt wir geben den menschen auch das
demonstrationsrecht noch einmal zurück
als königsrecht der demokratie und
deswegen würde ich nie sagen das ist
schlecht ist wenn menschen demonstrieren
im gegenteil das ist gerade bei solchen
grundrechtseingriffen wie wir sie
erleben die sind ja einzigartig in der
geschichte der bundesrepublik wichtig
dass man den menschen gelegenheit gibt
dazu auch kritik zu üben
und natürlich ist wenn ein urteil des
verfassungsgerichtshofs kommt dass auch
zunächst mal ein beleg dafür dass unsere
verfassung funktioniert die verfasstheit
unseres staates dass der rechtsstaat
funktioniert das eben politisches
handeln auch von der frage richten nicht
mehr hinterfragt sondern auch korrigiert
wird
damals gab es ein paradigmenwechsel der
seitens der landesregierung angekündigt
war weg von der ausgangs beschränkung
hin zu einer bewegungsfreiheit mit
einschränkungen und dennoch hat das
gericht damals gesagt wir gehen noch
etwas weiter als dass die politik wollte
indem man gesagt hat es dürfen sich
familienangehörige miteinander treffen
das hatten wir zu diesem zeitpunkt noch
nicht vor
damit muss man dann eben das gehört zur
demokratie dazu
ein rechtsstaat boris palmer ist uns
zugeschaltet aus tübingen herr palmer
sie sind oberbürgermeister wäre die
politik der regierung kritisiert und
falsch findet in dieser krise musste
eigentlich gleich ein
verschwörungstheoretiker sein kann
sicher nicht ich bin anhänger einer
these die der frühere tübinger professor
lord ralf dahrendorf formuliert hat es
nämlich in der demokratie die
integration durch streit gelingt das
klingt erstmal paradox aber wenn sie
einen normalen menschlichen beziehungen
denken solange man miteinander streitet
ist man noch im gespräch
erst wenn man sich nichts mehr zu sagen
hat dann wird es schlimm und ich glaube
wir sind dabei einen ähnlichen fehler zu
machen wie 2015 als eine moralisierende
alternativlosigkeit postuliert wurde und
jeder der widerspruch hatte und sei es
nur im detail oder im teil der wurde
sofort auf die seite geschoben weil seit
ihr getränk manchmal auch diffamiert
oder wie es jetzt dann eben passiert als
verschwörungstheoretiker gebrandmarkt
oder man wird eben von herrn lauterbach
dafür verantwortlich gemacht dass so
viele hunderttausend tote sterben da bin
ich genau das macht was er für richtig
hält und diese alternativlosigkeit die
hat schon in der hafenstadt da und habe
dazu geführt dass millionen leute videos
angeguckt haben von harry potter oder dr
voc und anderen professor homburg
da gab es eine gegenöffentlichkeit aber
die großen medien haben das kaum
aufgegriffen und das jetzt da was zum
vorschein kommt durch die demonstration
das hätte man glaube ich früher an
können und durch mehr streit in der
sache besser gestalten
nun wurde aber wahnsinnig viel
kommuniziert wir werden gleich noch
klären ob das richtig passierte und
genug war und strukturiert genug war
mich würde noch interessieren was denken
sie wäre ihr vater helmut der rebell von
rem vom remstal wäre der irgendwie mit
auf den straßen gewesen jetzt in
stuttgart
also mein vater war ein sehr
freiheitsliebender mensch und diese
einschränkungen hätte er nur sehr sehr
widerwillig hingenommen der wäre einige
zeit jetzt alleine auf bäume gegangen
haben die zu schneiden weil da kein
infektionsrisiko bestanden hätte aber
hält er an der demonstration teil
da hätte ganz vielen demonstranten
ordentlich die meinung gesagt weil da
ganz eindeutig menschen dabei sind die
kruden theorien folgen aber sind hat
auch viele dabei die ernsthaft sagen ich
hätte gerne den schwedischen weg oder
ich möchte dieses oder jenes anderes
mehr geht es zu weit das ist nicht
verhältnismäßig das ist nicht zielgenau
dafür gibt es durchaus gute gründe
nikolaus blome ist bei uns kolumnist
beim spiegel herr blume ist für sie
schon klar auszumachen wer zum team
panik und wer zum team vernunft gehört
sind die politiker oder sind es deren
kritiker ich glaube dass wechselt auch
von zeit zu zeit mal wieder hat die
ganze strecke der letzten acht bis zwölf
wochen dadurch gekennzeichnet war dass
man immer wieder neu abmessen musste ist
das jetzt noch richtig oder kann man
schon einmal wegen lockerungen abbiegen
oder man muss man da noch einmal
verschärfen dass das irgendwie fluide
ist finde ich völlig normal finde aber
auch dass da vorne auf diesen bühnen
dieser proteste im moment echt irre
stehen und je weiter sich nach hinten
kommen offenkundig deutlich weniger
leute ihre sind und dass
auseinanderzudividieren glaube ich würde
jetzt die aufgabe zu sein damit nicht
genau das passiert wie boris palmer
schon sagt etwas 2015 passiert ist wo es
mit peggy da anfing das waren irre und
neonazis und deren coole these war
damals die umvolkung also gebe einen
geheimen plan die deutsche bevölkerung
auszutauschen gegen eine muslimische das
war mindestens so bescheuert wie die
geschichte mit den tipps die wir alle
jetzt ins ohr kriegen von bill gates
aber je länger je mehr standen da
zehntausende von leuten die im prinzip
ganz normal vielleicht ein bisschen
dessen team eingeladen waren
aber im prinzip noch innerhalb des
verfassungs bogens standen und nur ein
paar fragen hatten an diese politik von
zuwanderung und das könnte jetzt wieder
passieren das heißt das problem ist
glaube ich nicht die iren da vorne auf
der bühne sondern die möglichkeit dass
es am ende wieder eine massenbewegung
wird dies beim letzten mal eben auch war
bei uns ist michael meier helmholtz vom
helmholz michael meyer hermann von
helmholtz institut so ist es richtig ich
bitte das zu entschuldigen
die kritiker sagen jetzt herr meier
man nicht der lockdown brachte den
erfolg sondern die hygienemaßnahmen die
hygienemaßnahmen hätten einfach
ausgereicht könnte man das gegenteil
nachweisen
ich glaube man kann diese maßnahmen
nicht auseinanderdividieren
es ist so dass wir in deutschland stolz
darauf sein können dass wir es geschafft
haben im gegensatz zu den ländern um uns
herum einen sehr flachen verlauf der
epidemie zu haben
und das sollte man nicht vergessen in
dieser ganzen diskussion und ich
verstehe natürlich auch die
unzufriedenheit mit den dauer an den
andauernden maßnahmen und kann deswegen
gut nachvollziehen dass man anfängt zu
protestieren und das ist ja in unserem
rechtsstaat so dass wir das dürfen
insofern ist das einfach genau das was
was jetzt angesagt ist auch aber man
muss natürlich auch bedenken dass es
epidemiologische folgen hat denn dort
werden infektionen stattfinden
unweigerlich die uns natürlich auch also
jedenfalls besteht die gefahr dass uns
das zurückwirft und wir sollten
vielleicht das was wir erreicht haben
nämlich dass wir eines der wenigen
länder in europa sind wo wir überhaupt
keine massive auslastung wir haben ja
gerade die betten gesehen in diesen die
lehrer sind ja das ist ja das ist ja
kein kein zeichen dafür dass wir etwas
falsch gemacht haben sondern dass das
zeichen dafür dass wir alles richtig
gemacht haben es hat sich also gelohnt
die rabatten sind leer und an der stelle
daran muss man sich erinnern und man
sollte jetzt nicht hergehen und
leichtfertig dieses erreichte verspielen
und und damit um wochen nicht um monate
wieder zurückgeworfen werden man nennt
es das präventionsprogramm wenn eine
katastrophe ausbleibt oder wenn man eine
katastrophe verhindert hat wird man
hinterher gefragt was sollte die
aufregung
es ist genau da ja das ist genau dass
ich meine natürlich können wir einzelne
maßnahmen vielleicht wären die nicht
nötig gewesen da wir nicht genau wissen
welche maßnahmen war jetzt die wichtige
ist vielleicht eine dabei gewesen die
wir nicht hätten machen müssen wir
kriegen es jetzt im moment nicht raus
welche das ist vielleicht können wir das
in ein paar monaten retrospektiv
rausgekommen
wenn wir die gesamten daten zur
verfügung haben können das analysieren
können wir dann vielleicht für die
nächste epidemie lernen das war effektiv
das war nicht
für den moment wissen wir es einfach
nicht also warum diskutieren wir das
dann wir haben ein paket gefunden das
funktioniert hat und das ist doch
eigentlich die großartige leistung
dieses landes die auch alle bürger und
bürgerinnen bisher mitgetragen haben
und nur dadurch dass alle das
mitgetragen haben war das auch möglich
dass wir in dem zustand sind in dem wir
jetzt sind
interessantes argument verwoben man kann
natürlich auch sagen das kann kritik
immunisieren eben weil die katastrophe
ausgeblieben ist hat man alles richtig
gemacht auch das ist möglich
auch das ist möglich aber ich weiß nicht
ob dieses argumentieren also lassen sie
uns doch vielleicht noch ein paar wochen
oder monate warten wie sich das alles
entwickelt
denn wer mir immer noch große
unsicherheiten ja ich meine jetzt nicht
warten mit weiteren öffnungen oder mit
der gestaltung dessen wie wir jetzt die
gesellschaft mit regeln versehen und
auch regeln mal wieder zurücknehmen
sondern ich meine warten mit diesen
interpretations schemata weil wir ja
immer noch unter erheblichen
unsicherheiten stehen wir wissen zum
beispiel überhaupt nicht was eine
immunität wirklich bewirkt werden wir
überhaupt irgendwann jetzt mal
vernünftigerweise einen impfstoff
erwarten können bei einem neuen virus
der sich anscheinend doch dieser sache
geschickt entzieht und ein bisschen
schwerpunkt verlagert hätten wir nie so
richtig gehen wir noch mal zu den
demonstranten nikolaus blome haben sie
eine idee wo da eigentlich der graben
verläuft ist das alt gegen jung links
gegen rechts nein es ist nicht das sind
linke und rechte dabei arm gegen reich
und also sicherlich gehen leute mit
einer höheren instanz sind die von den
maßnahmen und deshalb wird er diskutiert
eben hart getroffen worden
also man hat es was immer man gekriegt
hat ein erfolg ja nicht umsonst bekommen
dass man schon klar sein
wirtschaftsabschwung und das zu bezahlen
der seinesgleichen sucht kann richtig
sein aber sie werden es halt nicht
wissen und sie werden es auch niemals
schlüssel fest oder gerichtsfest
beweisen können dass das richtig war
genauso wenig wie man wird beweisen
können dass die hälfte es auch getan hat
das wird beides nicht sein dass in
diesem buch muss man jetzt diskutieren
die politik musste entscheiden in dem
lambo und inhaltlich nicht darum und ich
glaube es sind leute die da hingehen die
mit dem begriff veränderungen nichts
besonders gutes verbinden sie mit den
sätzen nachgeholt wird alles anders sein
und ihr müsst ihr an
das leben führen die wirtschaft wird
ganz anders sein die bei solchen sätzen
er nervös werden als neugierig und
hingehen und sagen wo ich hatte aber
jetzt schon eine ganze menge
veränderungen an mir reicht das und ich
würde gerne genau zu dem leben zurück
kommen dass wir vorher hatten und alle
anderen sagen aber oder viele andere
sagen du wirst in der form nicht mehr
nach mallorca fahren du wirst nicht mehr
so baldauf volksfeste gegen die würde es
in der form nicht mehr geben
dein job wird sich möglicherweise
verändern und das macht den leuten
glaube ich völlig zurecht sorge und das
ist glaube ich wie ein soziologe
kürzlich mal sagte die alte mitte die
dörfer meisten sorge meyer hermann die
jüngeren sind von kogit 19 weniger
betroffen vor allen dingen weniger
schwer betroffen aber sie sind
offensichtlich die muttis bretter sie
tragen das virus tatsächlich als
infektion und die menschen wird man
denen sagen können dass sie sich
verhalten müssen als wären sie risiko
als wären sie selber in einem risiko
indem sie sehen sie nicht sind aber
damit andere schützen
ich denke in unserer gesellschaft ist
das wort verantwortung durchaus
verankert und es ist die verantwortung
der jungen die alten zu schützen und
auch sich selbst zu schützen denn die
sind auch junge gestorben abgesehen
davon es ist ja nicht so dass man davor
immun ist dass man unter teilweise ohne
ohne ersichtlichen grund also ohne
vorerkrankung die man hätte feststellen
können also wir müssen glaube ich bin
jung und alt vergleicht gucken kann man
eine chinesische studie hat es gegeben
über das kontakt verhalten von jungen
und alten menschen und da hat man
zweierlei dinge kann man feststellen
einerseits ist die übertragungs
wahrscheinlichkeit durch jüngere
tatsächlich kleiner also gerade jetzt
schulalter da ist sie ist kleiner
wahrscheinlich wir wissen nicht genau
warum vielleicht weil die virale last
etwas kleiner ist oder weil die ganze
infektion etwas kürzer verläuft also da
gibt es unterschiedliche möglichkeiten
warum das so der fall sein könnte
gleichzeitig und das sind die
chinesischen studie drin sind kontakte
fünfmal so viele wie bei erwachsenen und
älteren
das heißt wenn wir also jetzt die
transmission wahrscheinlichkeit die
infektions wahrscheinlichkeit halbieren
aber die kontaktzahlen 45
dann sind die natürlich die hauptstädter
ja und da ist da ist das große risiko
und deswegen sehe ich auch das große
risiko in den schulhof nungen weil weil
da eben ein sehr schneller wird und das
wird sofort in die familien in die
arbeitsplätze getragen das geht ganz
schnell
und die ketten sind schon da bevor man
sie überhaupt identifiziert hat eben
weil die menschen symptomfrei sind und
tatsächlich nicht merken und nicht
wissen dass ihr dieses virus in sich
tragen und sich auch um die lehrer
irgendwie nicht kümmern die auf dem
schulhof zusammen wie sie lust haben ich
meine das habe ich ja so auch gemacht
deswegen wäre es ja auch so unglaublich
wichtig dass mit einer vernünftigen test
strategie zu verbinden damit man eben
weiß was man macht ich meine man hat die
kapazitäten an den ganzen tests dann
kann man sie doch an den orten wo es
jetzt besonders umstritten ist und das
sind die kitas und schulen doch mal in
einer weise einsetzen dass man diese
unsicherheiten beseitigt konnte lud
müssen natürlich genauso die altenheime
sein boris palmer sie haben
morddrohungen erhalten ihre familie auch
anlass dafür war ein satz aus einem
interview wir zieht hier in denen noch
mal
ich sage es ihnen mal ganz brutal wir
retten in deutschland möglicherweise
menschen die in einem halben jahr
sowieso tot während aufgrund ihres
alters und ihrer vorerkrankungen
herr palmer wenn es ihnen darum ging
risiken abzuwägen das war ihre
begründung warum haben sie dann ihre
worte nicht abgebogen als ein live
interview war und diesen dummen satz
gesagt hab ich entschuldige mich bei
allen die sich dadurch geängstigt
gefüllt haben oder den eindruck gewonnen
haben ich würde jetzt alte menschen
aufgeben oder gar euthanasie befürworten
aber lassen sie mich einmal erklären
worum es geht wir haben in thüringen als
erste stadt in baden württemberg alle
altenheime und pflegeheime screen tests
gemacht für personal und für die
bewohnerinnen bewohnern wir konnten
dadurch einen ausbruch stoppen sie schon
begonnen hatte das hat viele
menschenleben gerettet
von den 7000 toten sagt slk ist ein
drittel in alten und pflegeheimen
gewesen und wir hätten diese todesfälle
vermeiden können wenn wir eine
konsequente test strategie für die
risiko einrichtungen von anfang an
gefahren hätten das ist bis heute nicht
gemacht weil das halte ich für geradezu
fahrlässig und das ist lange gar nicht
finanziert wurde kann ich überhaupt
nicht begreifen und es kommt ja noch
dazu im alten- oder pflegeheim lebt man
in deutschland wenn man dort ist im
schnitt elf monate das war der
hintergrund meiner bemerkung wie gesagt
sehr dumm formuliert aber das ist die
statistik und die menschen die dort
jetzt gestorben sind die wahren dem tod
sehr nahe aber wissen sie was das
schlimmste für die war ich habe gerade
die todesanzeige gelesen was sich die
angehörigen verabschieden und sagen
unsere mutter mit 90 jahren die ist
nicht an corona gestorben auch nicht mit
corona sondern an der einsamkeit weil
sich ihre angehörigen nicht mehr sehen
konnten dass waren über 10.000 menschen
die jetzt mit totaler kontakt die
situation vollkommen einsam gestorben
sind
meine kritik ist hat er nicht dass wir
alte menschen schützen ganz im gegenteil
meine kritik ist dass das nicht gut
genug tun und dass wir dabei ein anderer
stelle auch noch viel zu großen schaden
anrichten oder nicht bereit sind das was
in jedem fall dem plan steht endlich
umzusetzen
das heißt wenn sich die ausbreitung
eines virus nicht mehr gänzlich
unterdrücken lässt davon müssen wir
ausgehen angesichts der weltweiten
pandemie lage dann ist die protection
phase einzuleiten protection heißt
intensiv zum schutz der risikogruppen
der menschen
in gefahr stehen eine schwere erkrankung
durch zu machen weil wir es
wirtschaftlich und auch im hinblick auf
leben nicht durchstehen einer dort zwei
jahre wie herr lauterbach uns das
empfiehlt die wirtschaft so runter zu
fahren
die wirtschaft ist ein lebens erhalten
das system und die john hopkins
universität auf die jetzt alle schauen
sagt unsere shutdown maßnahmen werden
weltweit 1,2 millionen kinder das leben
kosten das können wir doch nicht einfach
hinnehmen wir müssen bessere strategien
entwickeln zum schutz unserer
risikogruppen und die gibt es hätte man
muss man tatsächlich risikogruppen und
in diesem fall ältere menschen weil es
sie wesentlich mehr betrifft besser
schützen müssen
es wird immer vom besseren schutz der
alten gesprochen warum tun wir das so
wenig ja das weiß ich nicht aber
natürlich ist es sinnvoll dass wir mehr
testen in den altenheimen weil da eben
die risikogruppen sind ich möchte nur
eine falschinformation die hier jetzt
offensichtlich ohne widerspruch
hingenommen wird noch mal dahin sind sie
daran
deswegen bin ich offensichtlich daran
jetzt es ist es gibt eine untersuchung
in deutschland wie lange die menschen
die an corona gestorben sind noch
geliebt hätten das ist im durchschnitt
neun jahre
es handelt sich also nicht sagen es ist
schön dass ich das für falsch halten
haben war hätte ich mich über mein und
wir reden über wissenschaftliche fakten
und ja und ich sage ihnen einfaches
bares gegen arbeit wenn ein drittel der
menschen in der einrichtung war wo alle
nur noch im schnitt elf monate leben
dann kann es nicht sein dass er sucht ja
nur in dieser heinrich jahre war 81
jahre durch die einrichtung kleiner teil
der statistik entschuldigung also große
tann ein drittel war der toten war ein
pflegeheim seit neun jahren hätte ich
auch alle das bedeutet dass es also sehr
viele gibt die wesentlich länger noch
gelebt hätten
nagel ebenfalls sehr wichtig und in
england in england ist es übrigens die
gleiche analyse gemacht worden da kommt
man auf zehn jahre
man muss man mit den leuten reden
krankenhaus tätig sind und ich war
gerade letzte woche noch mal am
universitätsklinikum in homburg und habe
dort mit intensivmedizinern gesprochen
die eben auch und gerade von patienten
berichtet haben die im besten alter
waren die sind noch vor 14 tagen
gewandert
und dann ging es gut die haben
lebenserwartung von 30 35 jahren noch
vor sich möglicherweise und die
erkranken so schwer dass sie ihr leben
kämpfen wir haben einen patienten
entlassen
da wurde nicht zehn tage beatmet nicht
20 tage beatmet er wurde über vier
wochen beatmet also da gibt es schon
wirklich patienten die auch ohne
bekannte vorerkrankungen oder zumindest
man mit einer großen lebensqualität die
sie normalerweise gehabt hätten hier
behandelt werden müssen an dieser
erkrankung und ich will vielleicht auch
mal an dieser stelle eine lanze brechen
für die jungen menschen weil das jetzt
eben so rübergekommen ist als während es
vor allem die jungen die sich dagegen
wehren ich krieg unglaublich viele
zuschriften gerade von schülerinnen und
schülern die mir sagen wir machen uns
große sorgen wir wollen vorsichtig sein
wir wollen unsere großeltern oder
kranken menschen in der familie wenn
krebserkrankungen da sie nicht in gefahr
bringen und deswegen ist es glaube ich
auch falsch zu sagen die schülerinnen
und schüler halten sich grundsätzlich
nicht an die regel natürlich gibt es das
aber das gibt es genauso gut in anderen
gruppen und ich kann sagen im saarland
ist der schulstart nach dieser schweren
krise gut angelaufen und schülerinnen
und schüler aber auch die lehrkräfte tun
alles dafür dass man jetzt mal ein
bisschen abstand voneinander hält und
das hat noch keinen umgetauft egal ob
sagen wir unbedingt etwas denn es ist
das eine ist die frage der wissenschaft
ob das jetzt 11 monate oder neun jahre
oder noch mehr sind es andere ist die
ethische frage ist das denn überhaupt
relevant wie lange die menschen länger
gelebt haben das kann doch gar nicht
zählen in einem land und wir die würde
des menschen in artikel 1 unserer
verfassung stehen haben universen und wo
wir auch bei den triage entscheidungen
nicht danach gehen wie alt ein mensch
ist oder was er noch für eine
lebenserwartung hat sondern wird dann
entscheiden würden ob überhaupt einen
überlebenschancen besteht das heißt es
verbietet sich doch gerade überhaupt
über diese lebens länge zu sprechen und
die zu erwartenden monate das passt in
eine touristische sozialistisch denken
der gesellschaft in andere kulturkreise
aber nicht nach deutschland und dennoch
herr blume ist ja interessant also nur
um auf diesen punkt noch mal zu kommen
ist ja interessant das völlig anders
formuliert aber sich auch der
bundestagspräsident wolfgang schäuble zu
wort gemeldet hat der hat gesagt
dass der schutz des lebens ist nicht
absolut zu setzen
einen absoluten wert gibt damit bewegen
wir alle irgendwie denn sonst müsste man
jede autobahn schließen daher ganz viele
sachen sind nicht mehr machen dürften
wenn sie sagen das vermeiden eines
todesfalles die oberste leitung unseres
handelns das ist es eben nicht aus guten
englischen aber auf jeden fall
alltagspraktischen abwägung ist es das
einfach nicht
ich fand nur an dem vorschlag von boris
palmer einen echten widerspruch denn
wenn zu recht alte menschen beklagen
oder die angehörigen dass ihre älteren
familienmitglieder jetzt gestorben sind
holen dass man sich noch mal besuchen
konnte dann wäre das ja genau eintreten
wenn man die älteren so schützt wie
vorgeschlagen denn das hieße ja man
müsste wirklich einen zaun um jedes
altersheim machen
damit keiner mehr rein kommt er ein
virus hinein schleppen kann und das
würde glaube ich etwas das noch mal eine
gruppe aus der gesellschaft heraus
nehmen auf dauer dass man das glaube ich
auch nicht verantworten kann ich glaube
so das war ein grüner herr ströbele
dagegen genau klagen wollte wenn es dazu
gekommen wären
das ist ja auch nicht mehr nötig wir
haben mittlerweile haben wir
schutzkleidung die wir vorher nicht
hatten das ist sehr zu beklagen dass wir
sie nicht hatten aber jetzt haben wir
sie wir haben masken pflichten überall
wir haben auch mehr schutzkleidung wenn
man jemanden besuchen gehen möchte der
vielleicht erkrankt es gibt mittlerweile
in allen bundesländern möglichkeit und
auch in alten- und pflegeheim nochmal
seine angehörigen zu besuchen wir machen
das im saarland vornehmlich draußen man
kann plexiglas dazwischen tun
wir haben doch unglaublich viel gelernt
innerhalb dieser kürzesten zeit und es
ging doch zu beginn einfach nur darum
dass nicht das passiert was wir in
bergamo erlebt haben oder im elsass
erlebt haben und ich möchte nicht
tauschen mit diesen regionen wo es
ebenso dramatische zustände gegeben hat
jetzt da wir weiter sind
und da wird es auch eingedämmt haben
können wir doch jetzt alles daran setzen
dass wir auch ein stück weit mehr
normalität für die menschen bekommen und
das ist auch unsere aufgabe deswegen
sagte ich ja die beschränkung eben nur
so lange aufrecht erhalten wie es zwingt
sie müssen